[Music]
welcome back to the special edition of
Hannity Democrats are in panic mode
heading into
2024 as Joe Biden's poll numbers
continue to plummet Nationwide and in
the swing States so what's the left's
game plan it's simple change the rules
and kick their opponent off the
ballot earlier today President Biden
declined to comment on the Colorado
Supreme Court's decision but asserted
that Trump supported an Insurrection
he's absolutely sure take a look whether
the 14 amendment applies will let the
court make that decision but he
certainly supported an Insurrection no
question about it none zero and uh he
seems to be doubling down on about
everything of course Trump hasn't been
charged or convicted of insurrection but
the left celebrated the Court's vast
overreach in Colorado turns out not
everyone is on board 2024 independent
candidate RFK Jr warned the decision
could lead to problems down the road and
South Dakota governor Christy gome said
what they're doing in Colorado is
Biden's Only Hope of winning the
election in
November joining us to tell us more
Governor gnome good evening thank you
good evening kellyan thank you thank you
so much for inviting me I appreciate
abolutely so Governor I think it's a
very important point you make and RFK Jr
of all people took to formerly known as
Twitter and really gave a robust offense
of the people said that we can't let the
courts and political manipulation decide
our presidents that right belongs to the
people but as a governor what would you
say if your highest court was to deny
someone access to the
ballot well what they're doing is
unconstitutional and it has no grounds I
think what is key is what you said
earlier kellyan and that was that he
hasn't been charged or convicted at all
of insurrection and so it's interesting
that the Colorado Supreme Court has used
this as the basis for their reason for
removing him from the ballot so that's
the hypocrisy that we're seeing right
here of how they're trying to work the
system in a very um unfair way because
they're so concerned the left is so
concerned about losing this election to
president Trump he will win U make no
mistake regardless of what Colorado does
uh and what their Supreme Court decides
that President Trump will win the
primary election he'll win the general
election and that's because of the left
consistently taking Extreme Measures
like this and degrading our society and
destroying America from its foundation
and up and if he does win again I'm sure
he'll return to Mount Rushmore to be
with you and the and everyone else in
South Dakota for a July 4th celebration
so Governor gome would you be able to
Bar Biden from the ballot in your state
of South Dakota if say he violated that
part of the 14th amendment by unfreezing
assets for Iran or allowed terrorists to
just openly walk over the southern
border I mean do you think that you'd
have that power or your highest court
would have that
power you know I don't believe so that's
what is so um interesting it's you know
the the process that the court has is a
balance to our federal government uh it
is a balance to our executive branch a
balance to our legislative branch um you
know so us exerting the kind of
influence on the court and their
decisions to take that kind of action is
really unprecedented so I trust our
South Dakota state laws our constitution
it gives great guidance to us and our
court system understands that their job
uh is to follow statute and give
decisions based on the scales of Justice
U I'm very proud of what we do here in
South Dakota I would be hopeful that
other states would do that and not let
liberal judges rewrite the rules of the
game to work for their political
interests uh this is where the Supreme
Court will should and I hope will take
quick action strong action to reverse
this decision at the lower court and uh
make sure that they do the right thing
by the American people and make sure
their voices are heard president Trump
will win and my hope is that they allow
this to election to be held fairly and
let the people weigh in and to choose
the president that they want in the
White House and Governor Nome in light
of yesterday's Colorado Supreme Court
decision many around president Trump but
many others are crying election
interference we know all about voter
exclusion voter intimidation this almost
seems like voter elimination supplanting
the will of the people with a Judicial
with judicial
uh imperiousness it just also strikes
some people Governor gnome something
we're both familiar with that
conservatives or center right voters
Trump supporters being called deplorable
irredeemable Mega Maga now they're being
castigated and denigrated in a different
way that they can't possibly um be wise
and judicious in their presidential
selection so the Supreme Court of
Colorado must do it for them by kicking
someone off the ballot but what do you
think of that I'm sure you hear from
people all the time that feel
shadowbanned and censored and cancelled
um how how does this play into that if
at
all you know I see both sides of it I
see people consistently seeing the
hypocrisy and and the corruption that is
happening from the left and how they're
using this against people that are their
enemies uh in their agenda that they
want to pursue but I also would say
though kellyanne is the more this stuff
happens the more they normalize it the
more often that they use our judicial
system in our Supreme Court to play
these political games to go out and to
fundamentally rewrite uh justice uh the
more it becomes normal in America and
that's what is so dangerous is because
the more often you see something the
more you don't blink at it the next time
that it happens the more it seems like
oh well that's just something that
happens that is increasing so often now
in the last year or two where we have
our courts being used to punish
political opponents uh in a way that I
just don't remember seeing five years
ago six years ago now it's being used on
a daily basis I believe that's dangerous
for our way of life because uh that then
becomes normal to the American people
and they start to think that that is
something that is okay it is not okay
that's what's made America special for
so many generations is the fact that we
were a country of Freedom we were a
country of the people a republic where
they get to decide we don't live by
dictatorships or a direction of an elite
few making the decisions for the people
our motto in South OTA is under God the
people rule we enforce that every day uh
by following our constitution I would
hope in the United States of America we
remember what our constitution says as
well well fortunately millions and
millions of Americans agree with those
very points Governor Christine Nome of
South Dakota thank you for joining us
Merry
Christmas you Merry Christmas hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else